hello grammarians and hello page hi
david so we're going to talk about
using commas in dialogue so i've got
these two sentences here that i have
removed all the punctuation from
because i recognize that
figuring out where to put commas when
you are reporting someone else's speech
you know for a newspaper article or a
piece of fiction or whatever it is
can be quite confusing
um and so here's basically what you need
to know is that commas in dialogue
essentially function as runways you can
ramp you up to get going for an
utterance and take you down and land
paige would you read me
this sentence
guillermo said i have no idea where i
put that moonstone so we're starting
into this sentence
and we're going to use this comma as a
ramp
to divide between the utterance and
what's called the dialogue tag so
guillermo said comma i have no idea
where i put that moonstone this is the
end of his utterance we're going to put
a period here however sentence number
two
they're probably pirates roxanne said
so here since we're putting the dialogue
tag after the reported speech this were
otherwise going to be a period
uh we're going to put a comma here
the they're probably pirates comma
roxanne said
period
and why is this it's because we're
trying to separate between the reported
speech and the dialogue tag itself so
um
in the event that this were a question
however
you would use a question mark
or if it were an exclamation you'd use
an exclamation point but if it were
going to just be a period
you wouldn't do this you wouldn't say
they're probably pirates period roxanne
said you would say they're probably
pirates
comma
roxanne said
yeah
i know that's kind of confusing
but that is the style that we abide by
in english right so as you said a comma
with dialogue is pretty much acting as a
runway okay so with the first sentence
guillermo said comma so this is kind of
like take off right you're getting like
ramped up into the dialogue
and then with the second one it's like
the plane is landing
and
they're probably pirates
and then the dialogue ends cool but
there has to be a comma in there to end
it
so if if the statement we're going to
end with a period we'd use a comma and
report a dialog when the tag follows the
reported speech that's right otherwise
we'd use all the other relevant
punctuation marks yeah okay
cool
so this is like the only time ever when
you can end a sentence with a comma
yeah pretty much whoa that's awesome
yeah
so that's how you use commas in dialogue
you can learn anything david out page
out